Speaker 1: major breaking news last night,
and that is that the Jan. six committee
investigating the Trump riots has now laid out
in clear terms the possible criminal charges
against Donald Trump. Now, remember, they
can't bring criminal charges. These are members of
the House. They have investigative powers. It is
up to the Justice Department, currently guided
by Attorney General Merrick Garland, to decide
Are we bringing criminal charges or not? But
there was this open question for a very long time.
Would the investigation point to criminal
charges against Donald Trump? And the answer
now is yes. And of course, the million dollar
question is, is there a prosecutor willing
to bring charges against the former president?
So we'll start with a New York Times article.
January six committee lays out potential criminal
charges against Trump in a court filing. The panel
said there was enough evidence to suggest Trump
might have engaged in a criminal conspiracy as he
fought to remain in office. These are such strange
times where outrageous things are normalized,
things that would have been unthinkable at times
past. Five of them happen in a week and we just
kind of don't react. This is not normal. This is
a really big deal. Not only is there a committee
investigating riots incited by a former president
desperate to keep his grip on power on Jan. six,
2021. But they believe that he may have engaged
in criminal conspiracy. The House committee
investigating the riots said there is enough
evidence to conclude former President Donald
Trump and some of his allies might have
conspired to commit fraud and obstruction
by misleading Americans about the outcome of the
election and attempting to overturn the result.
This is a big, big deal. In a court filing in a
civil case in California, the committee's lawyers
for the first time laid out their theory of a
potential criminal case against Donald Trump.
They said they had accumulated evidence
demonstrating that Trump, the conservative lawyer,
John Eastman and other allies could potentially
be charged with criminal violations, including
obstructing an official proceeding of Congress
and conspiracy to defraud the American people.
The filing also said the men might have
broken a common law statute against fraud
through Trump's repeated lies that the election
had been stolen had been stolen. The filing
disclosed only limited new evidence. The committee
asked the judge in the civil case to review the
material behind closed doors. This is insane.
In asserting the potential for criminality,
the committee largely relied on the extensive
and detailed accounts already made public
of the actions Trump and his allies
took to keep him in office after defeat.
CBS Reporting House Jan. six committee says
it has evidence Trump and allies engaged
in quote criminal conspiracy. The House
Select Committee investigating the riots
said in a court filing it has evidence Trump and
allies engaged in a criminal conspiracy by trying
to block Congress from certifying the election.
This is the first time the committee has laid out
a potential criminal case against Donald Trump.
This is a significant moment in the investigation
because it includes rare disclosure of findings,
excerpts from depositions and interviews with
witnesses, including Mike Pence's top adviser,
former Justice Department leaders and those
close to Trump. Newsweek. Donald Trump could
face criminal charges after explosive John
Eastman emails revealed Remember John Eastman's,
this lawyer who laid out what a theoretical
framework for trying to flip the results of the
election? This is not normal, but and I know I'm
getting now dozens of emails and voicemails from
viewers and listeners every day. David, do you
still think Trump won't go to prison? Yes. Yes, I
do. And people who say, David, when you say that,
it makes it less likely he will go to prison.
No, I'm a random guy with a microphone.
Nobody, no potential prosecutor cares what I
am saying. It doesn't make any difference. We
have a situation here where think of the steps
first. There has to be some prosecutor willing
to be the first to charge Donald Trump, a
former president. That already takes a lot.
And it doesn't seem Merrick Garland is going to be
that guy. We've talked about Southern District of
New York. We've talked about Manhattan District
Attorney. We've talked about Georgia. Are any
of these prosecutors willing to be the first? I
don't deny that if one prosecutor filed charges,
Moore would fall. I believe there would. I believe
that there's many prosecutors willing to be the
second prosecutor or the third prosecutor to file
charges against Trump. I'm not seeing any evidence
anyone is willing to be the first. If you did see
that in almost 99 percent of these types of cases,
you don't get a trial, you get some kind of
a plea, you get charges being dropped because
things get complicated, et cetera. If you get a
trial, you don't necessarily get a guilty verdict.
If you get a guilty verdict, you almost certainly
don't get prison time. So think about the number
of steps here. So yes, if you want my opinion and
that's all it is, I don't think Trump does a day
in prison. Will we see charges at some point?
Maybe that's far more likely than prison time,
but that is still my belief at this point in
time. If you disagree with me, let me know